what up reject nation greg and john here with
our friend ace our star wars expert literally
he's filming with us so late at night when he has
a star wars panel to do at celebration so thank
you for being here buddy if you haven't watched
our episode one reaction that's up here on the
channel we're here for episode two ace where can
they follow you oh you can follow me at squad
leader race on twitter and instagram and you can
follow my youtube channel at first cut he's got
like an adam driver voice i love it yeah yeah it's
uh something like that i wish i had an adam driver
maybe that added driver meant to that guys
uh full length watch alongs for you super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page cover a
whole bunch of shows we're at the same to get
the option for reaction highlights and watch
alongs included if you don't want to do that
leave a like that would be very much appreciated
also subscribe and click that notification bell
to get notified when our next reaction for obi-wan
is up here on the channel thank you to the prepper
boys for helping us edit down these highlights
and lastly thank you to headspace for sponsoring
this video they have a special star wars theme
going on heads which is a meditation program
yeah and use the roof and get some face was the
first thing i started using years ago that got
me into meditation still meditated this day
so excited we partnered up with them uh for
mental health awareness month but more on them
right after the reaction let's do the reaction
this is one thing disney plus has brought
us is airports in the star wars show
has such a hong kong aesthetic it is
it's cool though very uh cyberpunk
if ever i needed guidance master it's
now spendy credits oh that's tomorrow
oh my god rex oh my god is it really rex
you think rex would recognize him right right
it's at least tamara morrison though okay it
might just be a random clone and yeah who's
not affected by order but it's it's it's the um
it's the fibo first i want some spice old man
i got a castle pure glitter stem and pollution
nice how about some information i thought he
was going to say you don't want to sell me spice
there's a jedi he helps people the
jedi are all gone i'll take you to him
i won't let anything happen to
you okay so camille is a gentleman
i'm sending a mother and son to your gate
you will let them through when they arrive
i'll let them understand that they
arrive i'm not leaving your mind
okay
it's all there oh you didn't have to
that's a great scam though i'm looking for a jedi
a girl has been kidnapped i need your help to find
her 500 to locate the girl another 300 to take
you to her goodness that light is unforgiving
what do you know of the force my
friend just there's a lot of remotes
and magnets you're gonna help me find
this girl i'm looking for yeah i'll do it
walter white action undercover kenobi
kenobi undercover breaking kenobi
breaking kadopi kenobi we have to cook
what are you doing back here oh what's this
come on man
spikes understand yeah
you're not a jedi anymore kenobi you're just a man
you're bleeding all over my
floor everybody believes smart
like how they just watched it
we'll see how this one plays out
i did like fleece scene there a lot
more there you go he's a much better
wait let go of me wait she's so little oh [__]
i'm gonna get you out of here why should i trust
you would you rather stay here keep your head down
there is a port across the city we need to make
the last transport you have no idea what i'm
risking being here your highness now and you'll
do exactly what you're told do you understand it's
the first time we've seen her physical this is
really cool it's also her first time off alderaan
yeah whatever power you are craving it will
not change what you are i brought kenobi here
you will be dealt with when we return once
i've taken credit for all your hard work
she's trying to link up with uh vader that's
what he implied right there saying you want
want to get to the higher power do you really
think those scum can catch a jedi i want them
to squeeze him he'll reveal himself eventually and
i will be waiting very much john works episode now
is a bounty hunter put this on
if anyone asks were farmers from tall and you're
my daughter granddaughter maybe what nothing
you're a little smart ass leo that kind of
attitude's gonna get alderaan blown up you
know that why aren't you using a lightsaber
maybe it's because you're not really a jedi
i read that jedi can make things float make
me float oh my god i mean she's a little girl
pick the best time to act like it you think the
less you say the less you give away but really
it's the opposite how old are you 10. you
don't sound like you're 10. i was thinking
the same thing he's like why are you talk like
a full-grown adult nothing like precocious kids
you're way smarter than that loot kid i
haven't watched he just pretends to pause
all he says is now this is we had him
look at this reward oh that's embarrassing
sis is with the girl he'll have half of
the city on now let's get to him first
make sure the port is shut down i want garrison
here i'm kind of hyped for this man there's no
ordinary jedi i was gonna snowbee is the
last ember of a dying age extinguish him
obi-wan is considered to be like one of the
greatest yeah fighters so taking it down
like a bunch of bounty hunters they don't know
how rusty he is though that's true that's true
i really love the look of this episode
yeah it's really love the look of it
there's a little sin city sprinkled
in here too it is yeah what is that
you did lie leia that's what you were hiding
you're the reason i'm here they took me to
get to you you aren't a jedi your father is
a very old friend i don't believe you leia
make her float just one little yeah just
wait
maybe don't run around the city with
your hood down obi-wan it's the girl
wow
careful you run right into riva
parkour oh damn daredevil force core
love the subtle sound designs on our jumps
my man
i support bad ass man
don't let go hold on tight
use the force man
no
come on ben
safe gwen great catch uh yeah he is rusty
oh he took the wind out of him yeah wow
he got downstairs remarkably fast he just floated
down the other side jedi speed force you really
are a jedi we need to move i love it he's slowly
becoming a jedi again the entire city is locked
down it's done you need another exit it's a
cargo port it's fully automated they won't
be looking for you there expect me to trust you
you're a criminal have i made a few bad decisions
sure do i feel bad about it sometimes do i
like credits yeah there's so much stuff you
can buy with credit go to these coordinates
they'll help you from there where is he
don't go
oh oh well they cut off
hopefully just a hand i am history jedi
where is he ah what did you ask you know what i'm
not gonna answer i don't need you to oh no oh man
that was a bad plan kind of practice aquaman
see harry i'm glad they didn't kill off camille
if somebody is offering us
help i think we should take it
now come on what now nothing you just remind
me of someone she died a long time ago
i'm sorry sateen that's a really good connection
though between satine and leia but they're talking
about padme oh it could have a little bit of both
in there it's designed to make us have this chat
let's see how rusty he is because
he should be able to cook her
ignite it come on my dude you don't
have to worry you're not going to die
today they do make those sabers really imposing
lord vader will be pleased you didn't know
no he's alive obi-wan ah yeah he didn't
know okay anakin skywalker is alive
god his performance is so good i found
him we have him and i cannot risk you
losing him again move aside guys
like arguing children watch and learn
this seems like the crappiest movie what oh
really think i'd let you take all the credit
damn oh i wonder how people can fight about this
you're dead he's alive are you okay
i'm just having ptsd just a moment anakin
whoa
oh damn
yeah menacing dude evil
mcgregor is perfect perfect
dang can you believe the grand
inquisitor is permanently dead
i was gonna say if you look hard
enough bring them back for rebels
yeah you can hear the fans
freaking out to die again
i just started rebels he does
it's the first season
he's gone get him a robot hand i
hope assume i think it's his face man
they cut his face off yeah i know his
he was his hips were a little forward
so one of the inquisitors just has
a necklace made of severed members
wow yeah oh i get it because
he's in that heavy makeup
it's cool they put him in the actual makeup yeah
eventually darth is going
to gain a bunch of weight
i want to see the series about that
this is a seat in return of the jedi
natalie holt is the yeah composer we should give
credit to natalie natalie holden yeah i think i
think so good good memory on you yeah she's great
did she do chernobyl too or is that a different
composer who is also not sure if only we could
access that's the mystery dude it's lost the ages
i i felt like the loki score was definitely
my favorite though man your favorite star
wars score is the legend yeah man of the marvel
shows uh that was a really great episode let's
talk about it man yeah all right we're mic'd up
we're miked up not professional so we're gonna
be talking about this i'm excited to get your
thoughts i'm half excited to get your thoughts
you know you can hear my thoughts anytime
but i'm most excited to share my thoughts
because i'm a narcissist anyway guys uh yeah
we're gonna hop into this with better audio
but before that a word from our sponsor who again
very honored to be partnering up with them because
headspace really helped change my life we want
to thank today's video sponsor headspace now
you guys might have heard me say from time
to time that i meditate regularly and it all
first started with this app headspace and it's an
app that i know john actually uses regularly now
thanks to me right it's all your fault and so for
this month they have partnered up with disney star
wars for your find your force mindfulness series
which i think actually works in conjunction with
the way of the jedi so well literally meditation
has changed my life i can confidently say
head space is a major contribution to that factor
so i'm excited that we're finally partnering up
with them especially considering it's mental
health awareness month plus it's perfect timing
because we've got a ton of new star wars content
on the horizon and with their find your force
series they have sleep cast breathing exercises
and guided meditations from some of your favorite
star wars characters including yoda chewbacca
r2d2 the list goes on you know i've opened up
about my prior diagnosis in the past the most
helpful thing has been meditation it's something
i very much heavily encouraged one step closer to
feeling like a calm confident jedi so if you want
to download headspace and find your force today
head on down to our link in the description box
download the app and get meditating do some deep
breathing hang out with yoda in all sincerity it
is pretty cool to be partnered up with an
ad that can sincerely say help change my
oh really you guys want to work with us that's
crazy um yeah uh ace why don't why don't you
kick it off man what's the first thing you
want well we'll kind of like combine a little
maybe uh kind of bleeding over from episode one
not not not a phantom menace you know episode one
of this but yeah yeah i mean would you we could
do both what have phantom yeah why not why don't
we review all the prequels and then go into this
let's do the whole thing this is a big package
uh yeah i mean what are you thinking of
uh what do you think of the show so far
i'm really digging it man i mean to me it's
trying to set everything up for one story
and i kind of i mean obviously we talked about
the bait and switch back in episode one with the
olea thing but i like that being the initiating
point or the start-up point to kind of take us
yeah to kind of take us where i loved your
reaction though yeah hold it closer please
uh i like that being the starting point to where
we're headed which is eventually a confrontation
with vader obviously between obi-wan and vader
him finding out that anakin is alive and anakin is
later they're all together in one and that this is
all set up for him to be you know confronted with
that failure um so i i i like where we're going
there's obviously some things that i'm a little
you know questioning eyebrow eyebrow razor
like what i feel like i'm not sure about reva
i mean to me it's more like the character or the
actor it's not even i think it's the character
because to me it's more like we get a little bit
of backstory as far as i hinted a backstory with
the grand inquisitor telling her that she
belongs somewhere else so there's hints at
you know a potential connection between her and
the jedi and something like that but to me the
final scene with her killing the grand inquisitor
even though we know obviously that he's in rebels
and then her saying that anakin is alive and he's
oh and he's vader kind of i don't want to say rub
me the wrong way but kind of made me go huh cause
i did for me too because to me it's always been
it's not necessarily like everyone in the empire
knows like oh that was anakin that's that was
he used to be anakin back in the day like people
don't you guys know each other you were his buddy
look at him now he's vader he's bossing us around
freaking freaking vader you talk to him for us but
it's not a well-known thing you're not supposed to
know that like that's supposed to be like a luke
obi-wan kind of thing for
but maybe i'm wrong i mean from my knowledge
i don't feel like that's supposed to i anakin
is dead like he's dead to everyone in the galaxy
and and vader is is a completely different person
well i mean i think what they're also doing is
sort of transitioning anakin even though it's been
10 years right 10 years yes that they're still
transitioning anakin into full-blown darth vader
because riva specifically cites that she's looking
that and that that vader's been looking for him
so i imagine that maybe vader or anakin is still
there you know because by the time you meet him in
in episode four and stuff he's like he's just
full-blown vader he's not anakin anymore so i
imagine that he's probably wants a little
bit of revenge for what's happened to him
and you know his kids they probably blame i don't
know exactly what his motives are but to bring
hayden christensen back and not just a guy in a
suit to get james earl jones to be imposing vader
i feel like there's there's got to
be some type of emotional grudge
that he holds against him and so i think there's
still a bit of a transition but i don't know why
he would open up to riva or whatever something
or what what who riva really is honestly
there are times where they're acting that i i
don't fully buy it's really when she's getting
like hyper aggressive or that or yelling that i'm
like it just doesn't i just don't you don't sound
believable to me i i i the thing that makes you
the most uncomfortable too honestly is sliding
someone's acting i feel so because acting is such
a vulnerable thing and you got all these people
looking at you and watching you when you're
filming and you're putting yourself out there
so i i actually get really uncomfortable
saying that i have a hard time believing her in
not every scene there are a lot some scenes
i think she does a a really great job in but
there's there's also quite a bit where i'm
like yeah i don't really buy you so that's
that's my weirdest issue with with riva i think
with grand inquisitor what you were touching on
that's something i think should have been earned
late that moment should have been earned in like a
later episode not that i wanted to start talking
about negatives because there's a lot i love
about this there's there's so much i love about
this um but yeah with the grand inquisitor it's
like that's something that a moment like that
should have been built up better as opposed to
them like bickering like children for two episodes
yeah and then you you do that and it kind of is
undercutting like his from the very first scene
he had she kind of just undercuts him and i get
that's their dynamic but then to do like fake out
death you know if you haven't seen rebels fake out
um that something about that just didn't feel
like earned in this moment it is more of like a
well it makes you wish you could see you can
see a little more from riva's perspective if
they're gonna do that because i feel like in
one breath it kind of builds up her menace
and her ability but i feel like if we maybe
could see a hint doesn't build up the grinding
but we don't this is an inquisitor for the first
time for a lot of people yeah so it is for me
yeah so so it's like what is what makes the
inquisitor grand you know yeah he's just got
an attitude speeches in his voice he's just got
the title and the title is the scary part it's the
way he speaks yeah if we could see into and i know
you don't have all the time to do all the things
but if we could see more into their friction and
their dynamic and what really motivates the two
of them yes see the grand inquisitor and why he
is to be feared the way he is and then get that
i think it would work it made me intrigued to
see what i i can only imagine it suggests to me
that she and anakin must have some kind of
connection he must have entrusted her with this
and so in that moment it didn't really vex me that
she would give out that information because it
seemed like okay there's a reason why the show has
been so bold about you just not giving a single
flip about anything the rest of your team is doing
um but yeah i actually i i've quite enjoyed her
performance from top to bottom so i i hope that
that story keeps progressing uh in an interesting
way because yeah i mean right now it's mostly
just been plot i like her parkour scenes oh very
cool it's great i love the sound design they use
on them too like to always indicate she's using
like four it kind of reminds me like the video
games when you play as like a jedi yeah and so
whooshing sounds yeah yeah it feels very much like
a video game and parts of her character you play
jedi i fell in order i'm assuming yes what is the
who's the villain in that the not the villain but
the sister in that yeah trilla trilla yeah there
are parts i don't think it's trilla who she's
obviously not but there are parts of her character
that remind me and and the position she plays
very much so uh so yeah i really like i really
like like i said it's not always but there are
some scenes that kind of do rub me a little bit
wrong with the thing that's really saving this
show for me in every aspect not even saving that
sounds like the show's bad and it's being the
thing i really love about this show like i thought
this episode i liked uh more than episode two um
but the thing i love most that is most rewarding
is something that i mean this is a big letdown
for people with book of boba fett for example i
think this is really the best thing about this at
this show is ewan mcgregor he is amazing here and
this whole thing with him getting in tune with the
force um again like so repressed something like we
talked a lot about it in the last review but just
to reiterate a couple of those points of this man
who's just so much in pain and so much guilt so
traumatized by everything that's that's happening
he wears that pain so much and he's there's
he there's such a resistance to things and he's
cut himself off from the force so much and it's
like him slow as he it's it's kind of like
obi-wan rising is is what's happening here
to the point where he can become like the ben
kenobi alec mcginnis that you see in a new hope
where he is in tune with the force he can do
the whole like let us pass you know the force
wave thing he can do all that um but it's like a
good wandering nomad type of character but not one
who's just like like just damaged everywhere
he walks uh so i i think that's been great
thoughts thoughts i feel like that's what's great
about the show is the show is called obi-wan
kenobi and thank god he's delivering every single
time he's on the screen and it's great because his
character has so much there as far as his emotion
his connection to the force his disconnect to the
force um his feelings to galactic political issues
to the jedi everything is there as far as the
character of obi-wan and i think that is like the
biggest selling factor of the show and it's so far
it's delivering in every single aspect so to me
i can look past like a few little nitpicky stuff
like inquisitor drama and and just really focus
on this guy who if anyone has seen clone wars
i mean obviously if you see the prequels i mean
you know who obi-wan is and they even kind of
hinted at it i kind of like that little line
and i was talking over it a little bit sorry
um but it was when the grand inquisitor said
like you know this is obi-wan so like be on
be ready or be on your feet like i forgot
he's exactly what he said but he said like
this guy's different like fiercest jedi in the
game yeah like this isn't the safety brother jedi
this is uh this is like one of the greatest jedi's
ever like this guy's like top three top four right
up there with mason uh and yoda and they even said
it in episode one with that setup as far as anakin
recalling his line and attacking the clones when
he said he's as powerful as master mace and uh as
wise as master yoda uh and then the prequels alone
he beats anakin and he beats him yeah and he cooks
him he cooks general grievous beats he kicks his
ass like obi wants like a badass like a straight
up badass like in the clone wars he fights
off mandalorians he fights off maul and savage
and i appreciate like i watch the movie i
like i like this like 90s action movie thing
of a guy who's been out of the game and forced
to get back and has to protect little girl
you know like it's such a professional a lot of
it's not even just a nice action thing this is
a very common action storyline of a guy pulled
back into the field that he's protecting a kid you
know like that's a very common action storyline
but what i really like is they are really
earning or slowly building him being able to be
full full jedi again or fully skilled because
you know a lot of movies it usually takes them
like one fight scene to just be a little rusty
then they're back in the game we're here i'm
like oh he is so rusty like he almost let leo die
like yeah he is wildly rusty that that that
shocked me definitely for sure because i mean
again if you've seen anything as far as clone
wars or even the prequels go he's his force
abilities are like hella strong like obi-wan's
got like super powerful abilities and he he's like
20 pounds of leo and it's just like really man
like come on bro put your back into it yeah
that's true yeah yeah i mean i i appreciate it
a lot yeah what do you think about the direction
johnny i've liked the direction quite a bit i mean
it's um i think it's got a really really locked in
sense of style and it's got a smooth i mean you
mentioned in the last one it kind of oscillating
between movie and tv show kind of feel and i
thought this one felt more unified as a more
cinematic yeah more cinematic generally and i
think like i i really like what deborah chow's
been doing overall behind the camera like i think
i mean one of my favorite aspects of all of these
expansions is often that tone that ineffable star
wars tone that is bolstered by so many things
like music and and visual motifs and you know
beloved characters animatronics blah blah blah
but you know to go into this and to
have an uh daiyu another place that's
newish and you know can bring some aesthetics that
evoke some other things like it's fun to look at
these things and not only have all the easter
eggs but also be able to look at other movies
and say okay there's a little bit of sin city
here there's a little bit of blade runner here
and uh and like you said even like the classic
kind of it's like obi-wan the professional
you know uh and yeah i'm i'm curious to see how
it builds and increases momentum because i feel
like right now it is a very plot oriented show
like there's some really nice emotional beats
and i just want to walk around more in that stuff
because when uh you know they're balancing and
this is credit to the direction like there
are times when it's balancing an action
scene with just you know emoting emotive acting
from ewan mcgregor and both are just as potent
and i would love for the rest of the writing to
kind of encompass that dynamic because i feel like
it's really there in the direction i'm trying to
figure out what the definitive tone of the show is
that's something because it's like they
feel so different these two episodes but
they're so tethered at the same time it's
like so serial um whereas like mandalorian
seem to like nail its tone right away like you
know that you can literally just cue that song
with that flute and you're like that's
the tone of the mandalorian right there
that's the mandalorian um whereas like the tone
here i'm like what is the exact tone and the
definitive pace of the show because there are
some things i love i love the direction with like
the way they handle the lightsabers like you've
pointed out there's such a menace to it um i think
i think like the show is yet to bro approach
yeah okay i'm going with that word is yet to
get to the point of what the trailers elicited
for me like the trailers elicited such like a
like a cinematic freaking uh
introspective tone poem heavy
um like you're really gonna overrate this
character and feel this transformation yeah yeah
it hasn't quite reached that yet for me it still
seems like it's a bit at odds with being that show
and fun it it paid i feel like it in a lot of
ways looks and paces and behaves like that but
i wanted to speak like that right i feel like in
the writing they could do more character for the
amount of plot like it does feel for as cinematic
as aspects of it are very kind of straightforward
in a sense in a way that i'm a little surprised
by i guess fight us ace well i mean i i just
think it's early i just think it's a little it's a
little it's a little early so it's been 90 minutes
we are a third of the way through this
i'm in act one it's two episodes down
we got a lot of time we gotta we got a lot of
episodes i feel like we can reach that by the time
we get through the final episodes and i think once
we get more hayden christensen and there will be a
whole other level perhaps that the show will go to
yeah i i want to ask you guys obviously there's so
much i want to ask you guys just because i want
to hear your perspectives um obviously we see
that final scene with obi-wan awaking anakin as
he says anakin and he responds to it i just think
it's funny he responds to it when when obviously
if you've seen rebels and if you see any other
media darth vader just basically killed anakin
in his brain like it's it's like a person he
doesn't acknowledge it's like a completely
different person so the fact that he awoke
as soon as obi-wan called him out in the force
almost like calling to him uh was something that
was interesting to me because to me it was like
oh he's responding to his old name which is anakin
but rebels was later it is later it's true but
but i feel like that's something that he took on
pretty early on after revenge of the sith
but again i'm not sure exactly how early
on but how do you feel about him being in
the makeup and having hidden christensen
act through through that is is that i think that's
a gift for a performer i think that allows you to
like when you have all that makeup usually for an
actor that that is a gift because it allows you
to lean into that so i'm i'm curious if he's
just going to sound like hayden christensen
he's got the darth vader breathing um you know
like when he talks what's he gonna say like
because you know i mean even in return of the jedi
when the mask is off he sounds it sounds different
so he's not gonna have james turtle jones voice um
so i think it would probably oscillate between the
two when he and he is uh but i i'm excited for
it i feel like there's a lot to impact because
i think what even what even mcgregor is doing is
something that is so much more emotionally stilted
than i was expecting like he does he there's so
much of just getting stopped in his tracks and
contemplating with his eyes like when he learns
that information about anakin you know that it's
just so such a mood there's such such a haunting
moment and it's like it just makes you start the
my brain starts firing and this just feeds into
what you're asking about it starts firing with
my god um like what is he feeling in this
moment like it's got to be a combination of
fear guilt worry and maybe there's hope a chance
he wants to reach out to me like there's so many
layers to that reaction that that was that's the
[__] about this show that i'm loving the most
when they just let the camera sit and do it and
let the actors in the world do its job because in
that moment i was like that is some of the that's
like brilliant acting because you got all kinds
of conflicting emotions reading across his face
it's not just like i gotta [__] this guy up
you know it's it's all these different emotions
that you could see even mcgregor experiencing
um and also being triggered so yeah i think like
i'm excited to see it's been washington's hannah
christensen see if you mcgregor is doing this
good of a job like what are these two performers
gonna do servicing each other in the scene
is what i'm looking forward to most um how
do you feel about it no i mean i i'm still i'm
still pumped i'm just curious if we're gonna see
you know more of the makeup more of him behind the
mask more maybe even a flashback uh which has been
rumored uh but obviously nothing confirmed or
did you get jake lloyd back yeah you should dhj
yeah that's great shrinks that will do
wonders for everyone but i feel like
you know you don't necessarily bring back hayden
if it is just to be you know that brief moment
that we saw him and i i think we we're gonna be
a full character yeah we we we definitely have
to see more for sure to me kind of going back to
to the tone of the show and kind of going back to
what the show is accomplishing so far in this
episode i think star wars has always reached that
both balance but also kind of
disconnect when it comes to goofy and serious and
and if you watch it and i can really pinpoint this
as a mega mega star wars fan who's seen the movies
too many times there's every single movie has
a lot of super ridiculously goofy moments even
empire strikes back you guys can rewatch that one
and at the same time has some really deep and
dense and dark stuff so i feel like so far the
show is doing a really good job of showing us the
dark deepness with obi-wan and then trying to goof
it up a little bit with kumail with leia doing a
little like you know running off on her own like
i love kumail yeah i thought camille was great
he was he was he was a wonderful welcome addition
i was half hoping it was a real jedi too i really
like that would be a funny take on a jedi yeah
and i'd be on board piss a lot of people off but
yeah i would still be on board how could this
guy be that balance if he's yeah but i like the
gray of him too like he's not he's a con man sure
um but at the same time he's you know he's still
got a heart you know like he just wants to make
money but you know when it comes down to it
if he's gotta do the right thing he's gonna
do the right thing so i thought i thought he was a
great performer and i loved like even that moment
i think deborah chow was like a actor's director
you know we you can see it in the most subtle
moments of of like when the when the when when
riva uh reads his mind on where obi-wan is and you
just see this like shame come across kumail's face
of like i would i was supposed to protect him that
was the whole purpose and now i've done the exact
opposite uh i thought was a really strong moment
uh for for kumail nanjiani leia is a cute little
girl a little adorable little brat precocious
little one the most precocious thing i've ever
seen yeah i i want to hear the the song like one
way i'm going to find you she's just obi-wan
chasing after her i'm gonna get you get you
just like waddling someone's gonna make that super
cut online because she waddles like the little
girl like it's like a cute little like penguin
waddle i don't know if you guys caught that
but i was just like waddling i was like this is
hysterical there there are times though where i
could use a little bit of a tad bit more nuance
with the writing sure there are times where i
i do crave it i'm like she's this one solid
note of this of this portrayal of this girl
she's snapping at obi-wan she's snappy doesn't
seem is is wildly fearless yeah like so to the
point where i'm like you can't be a real girl
like you this is your first time off alderaan
you're in the slumps in the worst planet ever
apparently and you're just like it's like there
are times that i feel like there's there's
not enough reactant reactiveness towards
out of you know like things that are truly
like if you're not feeling threatened at
all it's hard for me to feel worried for
you whatsoever but but i feel like that
the way they set up the planet to me and i think
john was getting added too was was really well
done as far as showing all the creatures even
even the side characters that had like two lines
like that little girl who was like you want
to buy spice and and then she was like oh
give up on the girl whatever like she felt
kind of authentic i thought she was great
yeah i think the world they built was great i
mean like you don't you don't get words like
that in the other live action shows a little bit
of mandalorian it's what we crave from boba fett
and you get something you get these kind of worlds
and like clone wars and stuff um but to get it
here i think that's one of the like that's why
i really like this one more than the other one
because this is actually like oh this is different
yeah this is cool to see yeah the creature effects
were cool um we saw a lot of uh you know
background characters that if you name them
all later i know you're here there was name one
checklist breakdown specifically uh it's like very
specific um no but there's a there's a character
in there that i i want to say is called weasley
but i might be wrong no i i think i'm wrong moment
of truth sound like a goddamn idiot but it's the
one where i think it is we asleep from a new hope
um which is the many-eyed creature um and there's
also oh yeah i know talk about it yeah i don't
know the one who bought the speeder um off luke
skywalker but there was a lot of cool like moments
in there for like for like a new rock stars
paws and frames like look at that creature look
at it eric boss knows he's all off the top of his
head if you pause right here at 22 seconds there
was no research he never he knows that all of
these videos are improv shout out to new rockstars
what up boss he's a celebration right now yeah
i i you know it's a cool moment for star wars fans
to see all those cool creatures yeah and creature
effects behind the scenes and i felt like the
world building there as i mentioned that little
girl who was trying to sell spice i was joking
around as far as the death sticks i'm sorry
i i it was a very serious moment that little girl
i'm glad i was waiting for this whole time for
you to apologize about it yeah the guy who got
excited to see the youngling slaughtered yeah
love it and uh i was like oh this is a
destix moment and i was like no it's not
i mean uh i i i there's a quality
here that i'm really appreciating
which is something i've wanted to see
explored a little bit more and i like
that they're capturing it through the wonder
of little leia which is the droids are life
they're alive and so much of the time they're
just like disregarded but they're actual beings
you know in this in the star wars world and
and sometimes you get characters you treat
them like actual beings and sometimes you get
characters you treat them like they're robots
and i really like how leia captures that
wonder of no this is this is a there's
a real per there's a real this is my friend
there's a real soul here you know which kind of
feeds into the whole thing of like entrusting
r2d2 down the road with uh you know sending
transmitting a message to obi-wan kenobi it's also
yeah i mean obviously that connects to leia and i
think of of obi-wan's connection to george which
is not not a positive one uh from what we've seen
as far as what i've seen or what i remember uh
rip r4 not not a big reaction when r4 died that
was uh that's obi-wan's astromech droid r4 p17
uh as soon as he dies remember those numbers
it's it's iconic because it's a joy that he's been
with for like 10 years and he dies in revenge of
the sith with the buzz joints and he's just
like oh my and he's just literally that's his
only line in reaction to it um and there's also uh
oh my uh attacking the clones his speech with uh
with a dexter jetster where he's launched my
memory here where dexter jester is talking about
uh the droids and the jedi temple uh reading
symbols instead of the little cup marks on the
toxic dart vague memories yeah and he's like well
if choice could think there'd be none of us here
yeah so freaking obi-wan racist droid is not a fan
of droids to be fair there was a droid shooting
at him this episode droid bounty hunter dude it's
more morrison your man's been yeah oh he sure had
a cameo here he sure put on a beard and sat down
for an hour or two if you're getting some more
abortion doesn't do as much as you think you you
i got so excited i was like oh my man's back i'm
cool nice nod i'm glad that you guys were on the
same sound stage why didn't they make him like a
rex or something i thought he would have been so
much more engaging i thought he was rex at first i
i can't lie i don't blame you for thinking he was
rex at first and then it looked like he had the uh
the uh 501st clone army that clung gruesome hair
man because that's the uh the clone regiment
that's assigned to general skywalker i mean
the clone wars i love how he just stays in the
he stays in the club now i mean
i mean if that's all you got
nothing but the um nothing but the armor on my
back and so he just stays in that yeah yeah man
i mean i just like one thing that stood out to me
from something you said earlier that i think is
perhaps i can envision being the sort of most
gripping emotional core of this is you mentioned
the idea that you know we get to a point where
anakin is dead in vader's minds is you know a
complete excision or thing of the past and i feel
like we meet obi-wan here in a position where he
is kind of grappling with doing the same thing
to obi-wan and just continuing on as ben and so
i feel like that is a nice complementary internal
struggle for both characters because you know this
you know there's going to be a flint spark when
they both get back together and you know that
their reunion will probably you know thrust is
going to thrust vader down that path of killing
anakin fully within and i think you know it's
going to thrust obi-wan into kind of learning
i guess the role of ben in the life of obi-wan but
what is most exciting about that to me is the idea
that we'll probably see that conflict and those
shades of anakin that are still left over and and
see that you know through the transformed physical
like because i keep thinking like every time we
hear about hayden christensen and his involvement
i always think of the hayden christensen
i remember and it hit me watching this that oh no
no this is going to be like a fresh it's going to
almost be like he's playing a new character even
though it's built on top of all of this history
and so i feel like that's the thing was like while
this start has been like pretty decent to me like
i'm into it and i'm excited to see where it goes i
feel like that's the stuff where i'm like once we
get to there i could see this really uh ascending
and transcending and really starting to sing
uh from where we are now well kind of going you
know big star wars brain mode uh in a new hope
obviously this is all canon we can debate
inquisitor stuff whatever uh also we can
debate the whole anakin you know revla stuff
as well as far as like how does she know that
but last time we saw them together in a new hope
i mean the first time we see them in a new hope
obviously he has that famous line as far as like
you know you were the master now i'm the master
you know that whole speech that he gave him as far
as like the last time we met yeah i am the captain
now uh which kind of goes to show that like
obi-wan still kicked his ass right so are we going
to see him kick vader's ass yeah because that's
the question that i have down the line because
we see that he's a little rusty but this is like
obi-wan like obi-wan cooks people cooks them i
mean they're gonna be building to that fight and
they said they're gonna have another fight yeah so
and then obviously again i know i keep bringing
up rebels i'm sorry you guys but in rebels he
like beats maul in like one strike because he's
just like i'm freaking obi-wan yeah one of these
episodes will be a montage of just him training
i was going to say thor loving thunder yeah
and then it'll end with him shaving his
beard i i feel like he would have to win um
let's say there's another there's another line
in a new hope about the tremor and it was that
he says a tremor in the force yeah something like
that and i think that's kind of what maybe that
was that what that moment was what we just saw
oh yeah with it with anakin and being in the
it could have just been a transition
to a match cut transition or it was him
sensing anakin it was i feel like it
was i feel like that's what they're
what they're hinting at i'm excited for them
yeah if anything what this is doing is really
allowing them a redemption a new association
for star wars and love for it you know that they
rightfully have earned and uh like look this is
better than the prequels to me already all right
that's some big words man i think that's hard
that's hard to fight one and two i would say uh
and i like i i don't the only star wars movie
i truly don't like really is episode return of
the jedi whoa don't like phantom mess wow i know
a lot of people hurts i know the the common one
is attack of the clones is the one that a lot of
people don't like i prefer attack of the group
i mean i i love all three but i love
phantom menace man phantom menace is
like one of my all-time favorites i
mean i appreciate when i hear like
thematically it's really what it represents
in the world like i like maul i like
i love the context and the purpose
it serves i don't enjoy my experience
of the actual film that it is that's my but attack
of the clones i i actually enjoy revenge of this
revenge of the sith i think is a
genuinely great a great movie i
i love revenge of the set yeah that's a great
film empire hands down the worst empire is boring
and overrated and last jedi number one my ranking
of all the star wars films goes in reverse release
order yeah number one rises skywalker two
last jedi at the very bottom we got a new hope
i swear man it's you guys invited like the the one
star wars fan who likes all the star wars movies
that's why i want you to be here that's the
business we want that enthusiasm because that's
rare so it's star wars communities so if you don't
like something i'm like that must not be that good
no i'm not taking the crap out of this if
there's a thing you don't like that i'm
gonna be if there's like a moment you don't
like i'll be like i'm gonna write that down
it's the worst moment in star wars moments star
wars history oh my gosh i swear i'm digging
this i i just felt like that i got a reputation to
preserve i swear i love showers i swear everything
about this show it's perfect no because to me
to me i just i don't want to be like i feel like
let's i want to give moses ingram a chance uh as
far as her character goes and that character shot
oh yeah i mean that's why i feel bad whenever
i say i have a hard time believing it because
it sounds like i'm saying you're a bad actor so
i'm like no i'm not saying that i'm just i think
there's acting in star wars have a dubious
relationship sure yeah i feel like that's fair
because obviously we have liam neeson in there too
and a lot of people didn't say he was that great
even though it's liam neeson i mean now the
department is one of the natalie best actors
of all time yeah i don't think she's decorating
the prequels yeah so what you guys are talking
about i think she's great but but i feel like one
of those things where it's like there is the tv
aspect of star wars has been it's beloved already
with the man lauren boba fett i think they just
kicked it off so strong with mandalorian yeah this
is so cinematic you know it and it's great but i
feel like they're still trying to get a foothold
as far as like where they want to be tone wise and
where they want to be story because i feel like at
least the movies say what you want of the prequels
or the sequels they know what they're trying to
do and you're trying to communicate as far as tone
story talking to the wrong man i've never read my
review of the razor skywalker did you like it i
freaking loved it i liked it
more than most people i don't
love it i love it i think it's great
i feel like they're still figuring out
i see you guys most people don't get
this far don't worry if you got this far
i swear i promise you you'll find at least like 10
50 people who are gonna be like i hate this guy he
likes star wars dude people hate me for whatever
i don't know star wars star wars is easily the
the the the community that i will get the so
i like this little lineup we have here yeah
hardcore lover yeah i love it and um you seem to
be liking this more than me that is pretty decent
i'm waiting for it i have mostly pleasant
feelings but i'm waiting for it to really
like kick into a gear that i'm like yeah i can't
wait i think i think what's funny is generally
what you've seen us react to together john
generally seems to kind of be more into it than
myself yet i know star wars more than john which
i find funny about our dynamic yeah yeah yeah yeah
you guys watch a lot of a lot of good shows though
right a lot of quality that's why this show is
good yeah but it's not all the other shows this
ain't breaking bad this isn't better call saul
well i mean i feel like if you do a lot of tv
watching reacting it might like i don't know
maybe you can rank it in a different version in
your head well i mean it's not really comparison
we watch so much different types that it's easy to
adjust to yeah compartmentalize yeah no it's real
it's so easy to adjust we'll have to like watch
different shows all the time in the same day yeah
it's really easy to just switch modes yeah well
in star wars it's fascinating because i feel like
oftentimes when you're dipping into it you're
dipping in on multiple levels because there
is to me a big picture of star wars and there
is the minutia of star wars and i feel like they
exude the most confidence to me when they're
diving into some minutia and it's always the
big picture where i'm like i don't know if you
all fully know what you want and you know because
there's been all that stuff lately about like well
we've learned from solo we could just never recast
any of these characters with other actors whereas
like that's what we're watching right now is that
happened but it was more agreeable because clearly
it's not a singular rule and so like something
like this i'm waiting to see all the way through
because i'm wondering like right now in a big
picture sense i'm still not sure what this show is
exactly doing aside from like literally filling in
historical gaps but in the minutia is where it
gets me excited and where you know moments shine
out that i'm like that's really cool and i hope
they build on it you know well i think i think the
the main thing about obi-wan is is the best like
the plot stuff surrounding obi-wan the character
is more of where i have that question mark
that you're bringing up but in terms of
obi-wan the character that's the stuff
that i i really appreciate that they're
they're fleshing out it's like this
guy had a you know after episode three
which was the worst experience of his life
then you hop into episode four he's like
otherwise than that you know i went through
a whole lot but this is you're watching him
do the grieving yeah you know you're watching him
handle like how he got to that but it's not it's
to me it's more than just a gap i'm like this is
a like specifically obi-wan the character not the
other surrounding stuff but obi-wan the character
this is so such an important chapter in his life
of how did he keep faith in all this and i
feel like and i feel like that's what we're
we're building up to already with episode one as
far as the qui-gon stuff we get a little tease as
far as that goes talk to me goose uh we we get a
little bit of uh you don't know they're right here
can we just i just want to take a moment to say
i i want a tom cruise star war i want
tom cruise in the universe i don't know
if i walk in the galaxy far far away i don't
know if i can sign off on the poorest people
but but i feel like we're leading
up to like you said i feel like
this is more of a character exploration
everything else surrounding the character
doesn't have to necessarily be spectacular for
me but as long as the character gets a little
bit more deeper as far as his connection to the
force because being a force ghost is actually like
being more connected to the floor that's a big
deal so we see him being so disconnected and we
know that eventually he becomes one of the few
people who becomes a force ghost which is not
you know which is a very rare ability yeah which
i feel like a lot of people from the outside
like i had to learn that you know like
that it's not just like oh you die and
then you become a force because like
no it's like very special circumstance
much you know intent and much you know melding
to and and meditating on the force yeah
but yeah guys um we got to get these videos
to you guys so we're going to wrap this
tom you're watching this you've
seen all the stranger things
we just want to give you time uh but thank you
guys for being here thanks ace for joining us
on this on this weekly adventure man
um and uh appreciate your insights
and thanks to headspace for sponsoring this
video and we will see you all next week or
if you want to watch more videos we upload
constantly so we'll see you guys every day
brian perry brian check this out you know why
you're perfect to shout out on a star wars
related video ch check the everyone everyone check
this out guys everyone's everyone around to check
this out it is generally thought to be a celtic
origin the name brian but its meaning is disputed
some believe check everyone shall decide it is
to be derived from the root bree meaning force
it's strength but mainly the keyword
force because you know it's star wars
it's about forcing people to
do things they don't want to do
um that's why they say may the force be with you
meaning assert yourself and create dominance and
power will yourself into situations and get
things from people without their permission
force may the force be with you
so that's what the word in mind or
i think we should go with force and
strength i think that's much better
so yeah man that's a that's a good name meaning
you are the spirit of the force you are one with
the force brian that's beautiful dude you're
you are forced in strength and you give us
strength by allowing by being supportive at
our patron allowing us to because that patrol
helps us hire people to do stuff you're a
big help like a wandering help guy but stop
forcing yourself to do things you don't want to
do i almost want to wait to for joe it's a face
no no bryce not brian thanks for being here ryan's
on that kind of force guy yeah brian's a consent